hello everyone a very warm greeting to
one and all my name is Krishna Kumar and
I would like to welcome you all for
session one of omics logic genomics
program so what is this program all
about advances in genomics are
contributing to the development of more
effective personalized approaches to the
prevention and treatment of infectious
diseases from tracking pathogen
outbreaks to fighting infectious
diseases bioinformatics aided genomic
sequencing data analysis continues to be
a promising field of scientific research
okay
as a part of Session One genomic data
analysis we will be covering the topics
on Next Generation sequencing data omics
data molecular determinants of a
phenotype overview of mutations and
variations core structure expectations
and Inter outcomes topics include
applications of bioinformatics
introduction to bioinformatics course
examples in biomedical research Pharma r
d and agriculture
so before we begin with today's session
let me also take a brief moment to
introduce you to the team behind the
program we are a us-based bioinformatics
company who is working with multiple
academic and Commercial collaborators to
develop easy to use analytical tools and
our mission is to make bioinformatics
more accessible
the omics logic training has been
completed by over 24 000 participants
from 187 countries in over 300 workshops
and due to this fast growth our team is
working with local and Regional
coordinators that are helping refine
local program Logistics and adapting
them to the needs of students and
researchers around the world this
training has been completed by
participant in six different
specialization tracks that includes
oncology infectious diseases Precision
medicine Neuroscience data science for
biomedical data and comprehensive
training on omic's data analysis
so how do omixologic resources help
Advance bioinformatics teaching omits
logic is a portal for practical and
theoretical learning of bioinformatics
it takes a combination of training
modules data analysis tools curated
project data sets and interactive
sessions with mentors to give the
student a clear path of the Bloom's
taxonomy permit and no matter what the
user's initial experience with
bioinformatics is omax logic is a useful
tool for gaining a baseline knowledge of
the theory behind bioinformatics
analysis of large data sets and
introduction to basic coding languages
like R and python or even beginning a
data analysis project
this program comes with an access to the
omics logic courses which includes
courses on bioinformatics Precision
medicine multi-almonds including
genomics transcriptomics meta genomics
and epigenomics data science that
includes bioinformatics using art and
Titan and example projects of different
fields which you could learn from and
replicate for your research work
users will be given directions to access
the T bioinfo platform for bioinformatic
processing and Analysis of data the
platform includes demo pipelines as well
as data management and Analysis Cloud
infrastructure to run binds marriage
pipelines different stages of analysis
are performed in different sections on
this multi-ohmics platform
so first of all let's begin by signing
up on the omics logic learn total before
that let me walk you through a brief
demo on what a completed profile on the
portal looks like
so once you sign up on the portal these
are the features you need to update on
your account that is a completed profile
will have a profile image full name with
appropriate capitalization link to your
social media handles this could be your
Facebook LinkedIn Instagram or kaidi or
even Twitter a brief bio about yourself
that will consist of educational
background and research interest the
mentors can view your progress under the
activity Tab and the courses you are
currently completing will appear under
the courses tab finally after the
completion of your course the
certificates will appear under the
certificates there so with that let us
Begin by signing up on the portal
I am sharing the link to the portal in
the chat box so the users can sign up on
the portal
all right so please click on the link
and I'll walk through the process behind
signing up on the total and for users
who do not have an existing account on
the portal please click on the create an
option account that you see here
so here you will be asked to enter your
name email ID and your password you also
have the option to sign up using any of
your social media accounts which could
be your Google Facebook Apple account
GitHub or even Twitter with that I'll
pause for a couple of minutes for the
participants to sign up once you have
signed up please put a yes in the chat
box and if you're facing any technical
issues for signing up on the portal you
can share that in the chat as well and
our team will be happy to help you so
I'm passing for a couple of moments and
once you sign up please leave a yes in
the chat box
[Music]
I'm monitoring the responses in the chat
box
all right we have one yes I'm waiting
for okay two years I'm waiting for rest
of the participants
okay great
so all right so since I already have an
account on the portal I am going to
click on the login now option and uh
sign in using my existing prompt
so once you sign in you are able to view
the various courses and example projects
under the courses tab so since most of
the participants are interested in
genomics you can feel you can close to
the various example projects and
courseworks that are available on
genomics
all right so now the most important step
that I discussed previously was setting
up the profile on the computer so for
that please click on the tab that says
welcome back with your email ID
so how do we edit the features that I
mentioned before for that click on the
icon that says profile and here you can
enter the necessary details such as
upload your profile image enter your bio
your name link to any any of your social
media handles so in my case I have
linked my LinkedIn and my orc ID so
under the activity tab the mentor and
the community manager will be able to
track your learning progress and once
you start completing any courses it will
appear under the courses tab so in my
case I'm currently completing python
course
and if you are completing any projects
and you're uploading it will appear
under the projects Tab and once you
enroll for any of the programs for
example the genomics program it will
appear under the programs Tab and
finally once you complete a course you
the certificates will appear under the
certificate stamp s all right so if any
of the participants have any query so
far please put them in the chat and I'll
be able to guide you otherwise now I'd
like to pass on the stage to Dr raghav
to start with session one of genomics
program
over to yourself
thank you srigori
let's
let's find ways to share the screen
while you're all busy
signing up for the
portal
can you see my screen
okay that's great
so I am actually monitoring the chat so
if you have any queries please
immediately type in in the chat box and
if that is appropriate we will have uh
we will discuss it uh immediately or if
not then I will address those questions
after the session is over or towards the
end of the session so welcome to the
first session of genomics data analysis
where we are going to discuss how we can
process analyze and interpret a genomics
data in general
so in today's session we will focus on
the core DNA code itself and we will
focus on how to interpret the variation
that is the main focus of analyzing
these genomics or this DNA code
themselves and what are the different
ways in which these variations can tell
us or can help us understand the biology
behind the subjects or biology behind
the study
samples that we are
investigating that we are studying so
let's start by going through couple of
slides of review so if you already know
this you can speed it up or yeah I'll
follow it along so um let's start
reviewing the fundamentals of genomics
genomics is all about DNA so we know
that so let's let's also review what we
know about DNA code and what are the
answers that we can find inside the DNA
code and we also know that a DNA code is
uh
they comprises of huge sequences of
nucleotides that are stored in this DNA
and how do we make sense of these huge
number of sequences and and what do we
do to make sense of them what do we mean
by making sense of this DNA core right
so if we attribute the DNA code or
genomics data to a book then the code
can be thought as to be organized from
letters that will form sequences
sentences and the sentences will form
paragraphs and paragraphs or organized
into chapters and understanding and
knowing how to read this code can help
us decipher the full story about who we
are can help us understand to look at
our history can also help us understand
how we as an organism or as a being are
connected to other living things that
are around us
so when we when we talk about genomics
the first thing that comes to our mind
is genes of course
these codes are genes that are the ones
that are passed from cell to cell and we
have approximately 3.2 billion letters
in total and these encodes to around 22
000 proteins and these genes are made of
made up of biochemical entity called DNA
which is a short form for deoxyribose
nucleic acid this DNA molecule is a
double helix that is two long thin
strands that are twisted around each
other like a spiral stairways so in this
DNA the backbone of each strand is made
up of sugar and phosphate and these two
strands will interact with each other
through nucleotide bases that is what we
sequence
so as we spoke about that this DNA is
made up of nucleotides so the
nucleotides themselves are made up of
three important components the a sugar
ring that is called deoxyribose a
nitrogen containing base and the
phosphate group these nucleotides are
the ones that are joined to one another
in a chain by covalent bonds that form
between the sugar molecule of one
nucleotide and the phosphate group of
the next this result in an alternate
sugar phosphate backbone and the
nucleotides of the two complementary
strands are connected towards uh or
connected together
and this connection that connects two
nucleotides of the complete sand is
called base pairing or base pairs the
base pairing connects these two strands
of DNA and this connection gives to the
characteristics double helix form of the
DNA
so in this example in this structure we
can see that the adenine is always bound
to thiamine and the guanine is always
bound to cytosine and they form the four
bases of the nucleotide a t g n c
so that's a very short introduction
about the DNA a very DNA and its Basics
so let's look into various ways where we
can spot the DNA variation and how can
those be helpful for us in understanding
the biological behind this
so we spoke about this and uh
what do we mean by studying the DNA
variation when we when we discuss about
studying DNA variation we always want to
compare the sequences that we have in
the current sample that we uh that we
are
that to the reference sequence and to
identify what are the places in which
the sequences or the bases vary or bases
differ generally so that this
differences in the basis or this
differences in the nucleotides or these
differences in the um in this DNA code
can give rise to
um
unwanted ethics which we call as
mutations are typically they are termed
as DNA variants right when these
variations affect the end product which
could be a protein coded by the specific
Gene then we will call this variance as
mutation we will speak about this little
bit later and depending upon what type
of variant that we are getting the end
product the mute the protein can be
altered uh in the sequence and that
alteration can affect the functionality
of the protein and hence we are ending
up with a
pathogenic variant that is termed as
mutation
the reference sequence where do they
come from so this reference sequence
actually comes from the first human
genome projects it which is what enabled
us to compare any given DNA sequence
from a human to a common reference this
common reference is what is compiled
from multiple individuals
T and this project is a 13 year long
project which started at 1990 and we all
know about what this project gave us uh
gave us a till date so the primary goals
of this Human Genome Project was first
to determine the DNA sequence and the
location of the estimated genes the
estimated number of genes at that time
was around 100 000 but now we have
filtered that and we have come to a
consensus that there are around 21 000
to 22 000 genes in our uh whole genome
and all the other sequences are present
to regulate the
translation of these genes into proteins
most of the other sequences so this is
the reference sequence to which we will
compare any new sequence that we will
see any new sequence that we will
generate and and identify the
differences in the sequences and try to
characterize the differences in the
sequences which in a nutshell can be
termed as genomics data analysis
so this
resulted or with the advancement in the
Next Generation sequencing technology we
have now actually uh obtained or there
is an ever increasing number of genomes
that are sequenced
uh
and the cost of the sequences have
drastically decreased and this gives
rise to more number of sequences being
generated and we in the end are ending
up with more and more data that has been
deposited to public repositories like
ncbi and ebi and we can make use of all
these public repositories to
make meaningful data analysis and
understand the genomic variations that
are present in the samples in general so
this plot indicates that uh the decrease
in the cost of the genomics technology
generally followed morsla until one
point and after that it drastically
reduces and uh which can actually give
you or which can actually give you an
indication of how the technology has
actually technology genomics technology
has
improved leaps and bows so what do I
mean by understanding the differences we
already spoke about that a little bit
more background for this
um
efforts such as the one described in the
previous slide variety of different uh
uh I mean numerous different studies
that will try to understand uh variances
or variations that in the genomics code
compared to the reference code it can be
uh can now for example detect
um harmless and also harmful variances
um
present in the as present in the
sequences that we are actually
sequencing just like just like
any code or just like any any sequence
of letters we can expect the DNA to
contain mistakes and these mistakes
actually occur as a result of copying
the DNA Source too many times and and
also these mistakes can also occur as a
result of various stresses that are that
the cells will undergo and these
stresses and the result of copying may
actually interfere with the copying
mechanism of the DNA and can introduce
mistakes and these mistakes are the one
that we are focused on detecting and
when these mistakes actually occur in
important regions like genes that will
encode very important proteins and even
the inside the genes important stretches
of sequences that are that result in key
changes in the proteins
that will end up altering the shape and
size of the protein and it can also end
up altering the shape and size of the
cell as it is given here ah can actually
lead to serious issues when that Gene is
being produced this is expertly
understood in the event of sickle cell
anemia where a normal protein sequence
encoded by the gene actually produces
red blood cells of a normal morphology
and when one single nucleotide change
actually changes the amino acid from
glutamide to Valley and that results in
producing red blood cells that shape
like sickles and result in reduced
carrying capability of oxygen and hence
it results in anemia so this is one of
the example of mutation or point
mutation uh one of the examples of
mutation that occurs in single
nucleotide position and all the
mutations that occurs in single
nucleotide positions are actually
defined as point mutations depending
upon what is being changed there are
several
um
types of point mutations that one can
characterize so one among those is
substitution mutation a substitution
mutation can cause several consequences
to the DNA code but this substitution
mutation implies minimal change that
only leads to single nucleotide change
as we actually discussed so what is
changed
one nucleotide that is in the reference
sequence is substituted by another
nucleotide and this resulting
substitution mutation may or may not end
up changing the amino acid sequence that
the tri-nucleotide codon codes for and
there are also other forms of single
point mutation uh which could actually
involve insertion of a single nucleotide
into a position in the altered uh sample
sequence compared to the reference
sequence this insertion unlike the
substitution mutation may end up
changing the reading frame and that uh
that encodes a try nucleotide codon and
hence from the point where the insertion
is observed the resulting protein
sequence may be completely different
from the one that is present in the wild
type or the reference genome and this
may result in A protein that may not
function properly and or that may
prematurely end and contrary or
complementary to the insertion mutation
we also have deletion mutation where one
nucleotide from the from the sample
sequence compared to the reference
sequence is deleted just as an insertion
mutation this deletion mutation will
actually change the reading frame of the
trinucleotide codon which produces amino
acid sequences and hence it results in
the protein sequences that is completely
different from the wild type variant
and this may also or this is also most
likely expected to change the
functionality of the protein and cause
serious defects in the cells uh
functioning and um
General cellular molecular function so
uh unlike substitution mutation
insertion or deletion may actually
um contain more than one number of
mutation one number of nucleotide and
again in those instances the resulting
protein May completely differ and there
is another form of variation or the
another form of mutation that is
duplication which consists of a piece of
DNA that is abnormally copied more than
one or more times in different places or
in a position adjacent location this
type of mutation again May alter the
functionality of the resulting protein
and some of the examples of these
mutation we will discuss in detail later
foreign
so depending we spoke about uh point
mutation and focusing on the types of
mutation from the point of view of the
amino acid sequence that these
mutilation encodes for we can again
categorize this mutation into missions
nonsense and frame shift mutation so a
missense mutation is characterized by
the change of uh point mutation of the
nucleotide level that result in the
changes in the amino acid um changes in
amino acid sequences right sometimes at
this single amino acid change that
occurs in the protein may occur at a
structural or functionally important
location and may end up being greatly
changing the proteins functions so in
that event as we spoke about as we
discussed the end result may actually
completely change the function of the
protein and hence affect the
um
functioning proper functioning of the
cell completely different
so a nonsense mutation is actually uh is
actually a change in the nucleotide base
change of the nucleotide base
prematurely stops the protein production
by introducing a stop codon at that
specific position so this definitely
changes not only the protein sequence
sequence themselves but it stops the
protein sequence production primitively
and results in a shortened length of the
proteins themselves so this can result
in a protein folding incorrectly or not
folding at all and hence the
functionality of the protein is
completely lost a frame shift mutation
is what results in when we have an
insertion or a deletion as we already
discussed and this changes the frame
which reads the tri-nucleotide codon
that encodes for different amino acid
sequences and hence the since the
reading frame is changed by the
insertion of this one adenine at this
position
now whatever is
encoded after that insertion position or
after that specific point mutation or
completely is completely changed and
this again will result in a protein
sequence that is different from the wild
type and this deferred or this
mutated protein sequence May again
result in incorrect folding or result in
a completely different function than
what the original protein is intended
for all these will actually affect the
cell's functionality to a larger extent
and depending upon what is
where this
um
changes occur in in the morphology of
the tissues and and how they actually
occur and how they actually affect the
cell and tissues and hence organism they
can be uh characterized into genetic
variation compared to mutation so
generally
all the changes that we observe in our
sample compared to the reference
sequences are termed as genetic
variations or genetic variants so the
genomics data analysis focuses on
identifying these uh list of genetic
variations and characterizing annotating
them into potentially harmful and
potentially
not very harmful and that the one that
can be ignored by just characterizing
them to um
to a different level so for example if
you see the morphology of this for
example in this example we have a wild
type
form which at in its natural form
without any mutation has this specific
morphology and that could be some
variations in their genetic Gene
sequences that can change for example
the eye color that can give a couple of
more modifications to the morphology but
if these mutations are no not mutation
if these variations are not going to
change the functionality are not going
to affect the survivability of that
specific form or organism they are not
termed as mutation they are generally
considered as genetic variants or
polymorphism etcetera but
mutate variance that results in loss of
function that results in improper
function that can cause diseases or that
can cause genetic defects are termed as
pathogenic or pathogenic and hence they
are called as pathogenic mutations
sometimes in several of the publication
this the word mutation and variants are
actually used
interchangeably but generally when you
refer to a mutation we always refer to
the pathogenic version of the behavior
and when you refer to variance we either
refer to changes in the nucleotide
sequences that are and that are
not characterized as of now or as of at
the moment of data analysis or they are
characterized to be
um
inconsequential to the functionality of
the tissue or organism so that is that
is the difference in ah
that is the difference in their
terminology that we have to keep uh keep
our mind so as we as we spoke about uh
how do we identify these genomic
variations right these genomic
variations can be identified by
subjecting the samples into high
throughput sequencing or next Generation
sequencing which you will learn a lot in
the upcoming
in the upcoming sessions and when we map
all these leads to specific position in
the genome or reference genome then we
can identify uh the places or the
positions in which that specific
nucleotide is changed or that
specifically nucleotide is converted
into a variant or a mutant form when
when we speak about single nucleotide
variant excuse me my
is Frozen let me fix that
foreign
[Music]
thank you very much so so when we speak
about the genomic variation that we are
trying to characterize uh let's refresh
our memory that what we have been
discussing and summarize into four or
five points so a single nucleotide
variant or SNB in short
um
uh can be characterized as a single
nucleotide change that may or may not be
present in whole or most of the
population basically this means any
change that we observe in our sample
from uh the reference genome
um is uh
can be termed as s and V or single
nucleotide variations
while a very uh another term that we
always
hear or but we always discuss is single
nucleotide polymorphism for example when
we have samples that typically consist
or comprises of more than one percentage
of the population or more than for
example not more than one but not more
than one percentage of the population
and when we observe this specific
variant in more than one percentage of
the population and that variant is
considered to be single nucleotide
polymorphism so when we refer to this
one percentage that represents the whole
population set of that specific
group of sample
that it refers to not the sample
themselves so now you can uh now you can
for example
appreciate the amount of sequencing that
has to go into estimating the one
percentage change of variant uh variant
that is presented in one percentage of
the whole of the population to turn them
as SNP for example the snps that are
characterized for the ethnic group and
race race different races like
Caucasians different places like uh
Asians and Europeans they actually
involved in sequencing more than one
percentage or approximating to
sequencing more than one percentage of
the population to identify these single
nucleotide polymorphisms for that
specific group of samples
or population so
any variant that we find uh to occur
above the level of technical error is
can be termed as single nucleotide
variant and any single nucleotide
variant that is prevalent in
approximately one percentage of the
population can be termed as single
nucleotide polymorphism and another type
of variation that we often refer to is
the copy number variation where a gene
is encoded in multiple copies in our
genome but the number of the copies
varies between different samples and
between different sequences and when
this number of copies actually varies
significantly between the reference
sequences and our sample sequences then
that may also result in the result in
the diff result in the diff resultant uh
result in the changed level of gene
expression and hence
may actually result in Altered uh
phenotypical condition of the cell or
tissue or organism engine so
all these changes that are characterized
at the level of the genes or genome are
termed so as genotype and many of these
genotype can actually
end up in a specific phenotype that can
be harmful or that can be harmless or
that can be potentially
ignorant or potentially
beneficial in some aspect for example in
this specific Gene one of the examples
of harmful mutation or harmful genotype
is the one that involves tax genes in
this specific example pack 6 is a gene
that will encode for tactics protein and
it has been
characterized and recognized that this
tax family of genes is necessary for the
development of eye in in almost all of
the organisms and surprisingly
the development of I in many of the
organisms follow similar developmental
path so we can follow or follow the
progression of uh this um this Gene and
their defects in many different model
organisms and experiments in such
organisms like mouse or mice samples
demonstrate that deficiency in fact six
will lead to not only in decrease in the
brain structure normal normalcy or
normality that leads to autism it can
also lack uh uh complete formation of
Iris or you can result
in cornea and that will end up causing
blindness in the
um uh yeah blindness in the variant or
the phenotype the blindness as part of
the you know type this is one of the
examples of harmful mutation there are a
couple of examples of potentially
harmless variants for example some
mutation in in specific Gene can cause a
long hair growth in in eyebrows or in
eyelashes they can be potentially a
little bit difficult to deal with but
they are not harmful in any case one
more example of for example potentially
um not very harmful but um
uh advantages mutation variant is the
SNP that is linked to or linked with the
development of blue eyes for the
Caucasian is is uh the variant that is
linked to the blue eye of Caucasian is
actually an SMP that is characterized
for uh
European and U.S race people so these
are all different ways and different
forms of variants uh that can or not uh
may not end up in causing difference in
the phenotypical versions of the samples
so
such analysis to understand and
characterize these variants can be
performed at many different levels to
investigate the functions of variety of
different genes in multiple different
research areas right these research
areas can include drug metabolism by
studying the enzyme function that
by studying the enzyme function that is
key in the uh
catalysis and the key in the
functionality of specific metabolite and
this can also end up trying to
characterize we can also end up trying
to characterize mutations in specific
genes that can cause tumor in that case
um genes that are linked with tumor
progression and tumerogenesis and we
already spoke about sickle cell anemia
this in case this um in this example is
uh
now it is high by the effects of
germline mutations that are inherited uh
from uh from our parents so furthermore
one can also use uh use genomics to
explore pathogens and to understand uh
important properties of their pathogens
as a result of their or as the function
of their genomic variance to study
virulence to study disease transmission
and to study drug resistance etc etc
many of these examples will become clear
as we review several projects project
and Exemplar projects as we go along in
the sessions as we go along the program
and some of this we can also discuss in
in the upcoming slides
in today's session so if you have any
questions please let us know in the chat
box we will discuss that before going to
specific examples uh that will help us
understanding the genomic variance
analysis
okay if there are no other questions
let's proceed
so so until now we have tried to
understand the concepts and the types of
variants and mutations and how to uh for
example characterize them so let's
understand why and how these mutations
hi
yes akshita this will be available
so let's understand
how how these mutations uh and variance
play very important role in the
progression or development of cancer or
better can we say
um how can the how can the mutations
will actually help in tumor formation so
we know we already know that there are
various important genes that play key
roles in cell cycle and regulation of
cell growth and Etc so any disturbances
in these genes will actually result in
dysregulation of cell growth and
eventually enhancing the development of
tumor so let's if if we focus on those
genes and focus on variants and
variations on those genes which could
result in tumor development we can
actually discuss
um
a couple of examples for example they
are these genes are actually generally
termed as tumor suppressor genes because
usually these genes regret the cell
growth and if they
um for example if they encounter any
defects in the cell growth they end up
uh
they end up inducing apoptosis and hence
saving the uh saving the eventual
progression or eventual progression of
the tumor and
development of tumor and progression of
the tumor in these samples but if the
genes if these tumor suppressor genes
get mutated and for example get
inactivated it will for uh or the
mutated version may end up altering the
normal function of these genes then the
regulation will be affected and
eventually that could result in
uncontrolled growth of these cells
so some of the examples of tumor
suppressor genes that you can easily
relate and you can actually
find everywhere in the bio biomedical
research area is a tp53 that we all know
about and P10 or some of them so
these genes that are responsible for
cell growth and potential mutation that
is caused in these genes may result in
promoting uh for example yeah promoting
tumor are termed as oncogenes and there
are sorry there are also some of the
genes that are responsible for cell
growth and if any mutation
um in these genes that are responsible
for cell growth can be
promoting
or
accelerating or actually in amplifying
their normal function that was the word
that I was looking for amplifying the
normal function and these genes are
their normal level that promote cell
growth but are the Amplified level can
promote abnormal growth are termed as
oncogenes and any mutation that results
in answer uncontrolled cell growth well
again result in tumor Genesis and we can
actually
um
find some of the examples of these onco
genes that are
hair 2 which is uh epidermal growth
factor receptor human epidermal growth
factor receptor her2 that is one of the
oncogene and some mutations in these
genes will actually result in this
receptor binding to a lot of growth
factors and promoting abnormal
growth of the cell and that is also
another oncogene which is epidermal
growth factor themselves right egfr
epidermal factor receptor themselves and
this again will bind to many growth
factor molecules and promote tumor tumor
progression and tumor tumorogenesis in
general and there are also other forms
of genes and other genes which which
will
which are um
involved in DNA repair mechanisms for
example and any mutations in these DNA
repair mechanism involving genes may
also end up changing the characteristics
of the cells to a malignant level so
some of these mutations can be acquired
which is the most common class of
the cancer they can be acquired due to
stress they can be acquired due to many
many times copying the the DNA code to
several generations and they can also be
acquired due to random chances right and
some of these mutations can also be um
can also be a result of hereditary
hereditary uh cause or these are all
termed as germline mutations which are
less common and the genes that are
famous for General mutations are the
bracha genes so if um if the bracha if
specific mutations in the brca1 and
brca2 genes get propagated from the
parents to daughters or from the parents
to cells
um from the parents to progeny then that
will result in most likely or
result in a higher risk of developing
breast cancer and ovarian cancers Etc so
some of the mutations that are acquired
for example
um may be concentrated in several
different portions of the Gene and these
are all somatic mutations or acquired
mutations and those mutations which are
known to cause human tumerogenesis or
simple progression or cost cancer are
termed as driver mutations and those
mutations which are known to be
associated with the presence of cancer
but they are their clear relationship
with the cancer development if that is
not known then those mutations are
called
passenger mutations and when one
discusses
or when one
focus on on one specific Gene for
example tp53 Gene which is very well
known
um for uh for its yeah for the for the
protein that is
tb53 and this protein as we already
discussed acts as a tumor suppressor and
regulates the cell division by keeping
the grow growth and cell division under
control under control so this the
mutations that are present in tp53 are
are of numerous uh type and also
Universe variety and you can actually
check right if I'm if I did not butcher
your name and you can go to repositories
like Cosmic and mainly Cosmic to study
potentially pathogenic
somatic mutations related to one
specific Gene so if you uh if you type
tp53 Gene in Cosmic then it will end up
listing All the known variance and
mutation that is known to cause uh that
is not to be associated with the tumor
development themselves so there are also
other forms of annotation in the cosmic
database which will annotate the
mutations to be potentially a driver or
potentially passenger or unknown causes
Etc so this tp53 Gene themselves it is
implicated in many cancers not only in
specific type of cancer many cancers and
it helps
as we already discussed it induces a pop
process and when it when the protein
actually is
when the protein actually detects some
abnormality in the uh
in the genes and uh and several of the
mutations that is present in the in the
specific regions that bind and recognize
DNA code can lead to
promote need to be promoting human
Genesis by not controlling the
replication of the cells with damaged
DNA so this protein will bind to DNA and
will identify incorrectly Translate
I don't know
replicated G A replicated basis and when
you observe several mutations in The
Binding site of these genes that will
actually
um that are actually usually associated
with tumor promoting and drivers and
there are also other variations or other
variants and other mutations that are
generally observed in the structure of
the tp53 genes uh protein which may not
be directly related to their
functionality but one has to say or one
has to
keep an open mind that we have not
completely understood the effect of
those mutations until now even though we
have understood many different mutations
on their involvement in tumor
foreign
so this the relationship between disease
causing mutation is not limited to
cancer in fact this is uh this
relationship and prevention has been uh
has developed a lot uh has been for
example worked upon in lot of other
diseases compared to cancer like one of
the very well known story is about
cystic fibrosis right cystic fibrosis is
uh is uh is as we know is can be
understood as it causes chronic lung
infections by uh by the changes in the
mucus secretion so it is usually or
generally caused by mutations in one
single Gene that is a cftr cystic
fibrosis transmembrane conductance
regulated Gene so this mutation can
actually result in either no cftr
protein being produced or some of the
proteins that are produced may be be
um
maybe yield formed or malformed and they
cannot perform their key functionality
in this cell and there are depending
upon what happens or depending upon the
variety of different variants there are
five class of these cftr mutations and
they can occur in different
different
stages from the protein synthesis to
producing insufficient protein the most
common disease causing mutation in all
these five different classes of cftr is
this is this protein processing or
maturation processing protein where this
one specific amino acid phenylalanine is
actually deleted and this actually
occurs in more than 80 percentage of the
patients and
and that causes uh uh in incorrect uh
yeah regulation of the of the mucus
formation and hence it results in
chronic lung disease
there are also other mutations like uh
like the one that is in uh like the one
that is in the in the in the in the
gating that involves a gating mechanism
like glycine to aspartate and which
causes complete loss of the protein in
the plasma membrane by
um by causing by by resulting in the
gate being too narrow so generally the
life expectancy of these cystic fibrosis
patients can be uh improved or can be
linked when we diagnose these mutations
early and when some of the symptomatic
treatment therapeutic regiments are
produced but um these are actually
results of
um hereditary mutations right uh are
they are germline mutations and one can
observe the presence of these mutations
uh when we look for these specific
mutations from the development stage of
the projects themselves right so
depending upon where uh this mutation
occurs as we see that there are several
advancements in
in understanding these cftr model in
understanding the cftr mutations has
been made and specific Gene modulators
for these specific mutations are also
developed and these modulated drugs have
the ability to for example
restore partially or fully the
functional expression of these specific
CF causing mutations and they also have
been classified into addressing these
specific mutation
um separately or accordingly so this
highlights in importance of studying
genomic variants
no I mean yeah that's a great question
komal why only 39 mutations of cftr is
considered for modulator treatment why
not the other 1700 mutations so we can
only act upon those mutations which for
which we can successfully generate or
develop modulation there may be several
other mutations and many of these
mutations May remain uncharacterized or
may not be reachable themselves the
modulators are also therapeutic drugs
that that has limited reachability or
that has limited functionality one has
to identify or one has to use only
certain targets of these certain Target
mutations of these cftr no so that is
why
um
uh we uh people are still working on
these modulator Productions and cftr is
very actively uh uh developing research
area understanding crtr mutations is
very actively developing the such area
and one has to keep saying that these
modulators will only partially uh may
only partially restore the functionality
of the cftr and um several more research
has to be successfully developed and
successfully performed to generally
increase the quality of life of these
patients
until now we have only succeeded in
extending the life expectancy of these
patients and eventually when we end up
in
end up in improving the quality of the
life then people can actually consider
this as a success story but nonetheless
understanding the mutation at several
different molecular level will actually
help us
generate a specific intervention for
those specific variants or mutation and
can actually help the help treat
patients suffering from these deadly
diseases in this condition right
so
mutations classified at for example
categorized as a single nucleated
positions are not the only cause of
disease not only this is Cosmic mutation
for example in the case of
um I'm not a professor yet komal thank
you so in the case of Huntington's
disease which is a rare inheritance
inherited disease we already know they
cause
for example a progressive breakdown of
the nerve cells in the brain and this
has a wide impact in persons functional
liabilities and it usually results in
movement disorders usually result in
cognitive disorders and and may end up
resulting in psychiatric disorders in in
there for example
we know that Huntington disease is an
inherited condition where uh instead of
point mutations that we have been
discussing so far a specific gene on the
chromosome 4 has an abnormal number of
CAG codons this is an example of
duplication mutation that we discussed
or that we just touched upon earlier so
where the CAG codon is actually multiple
times reproduced or multiple times uh
duplicated in the HTT or Huntington G so
this Gene encodes a very large
Huntington protein and these additional
repeats actually change the change the
structure of the protein completely and
this is the result of progressive
movement disorder or dementia Behavior
abnormalities
etc etc for example
the hunting the diseases
typically emerge in around midlife 45 55
or even later at that point but there
are certain cases and there are specific
cases where juvenile onset has been
observed and uh when when we can if we
can diagnose the presence of these
characteristics motor signs
um based on the presence of these
characteristic motor science then we can
look for these mutations in those
juvenile concept cases that is what has
been done by the Huntington Consortium
in 2015 which published a study of over
1000 individuals with early and late
onset of this disease and by by
understanding the whole genome
sequencing and understanding the
targeted sequencing of specific
chromosome 4
sequencing researchers discovered very
important regulatory mechanisms that are
differentiated between the groups uh for
which we observe early disease or early
onset and for another which we observe
late answer and that actually is
associated with the chromosome 50 where
we have abnormal
um copy number variations of a specific
Gene and and that results in the slower
development of the of this specific
uh this is progression and etcetera of
different mechanism of this is
progression and uh
this uh chromosome 15 for example uh
this specific uh
Gene in the chromosome 15 that got uh it
got that have abnormal number of copy
number variation
can actually help us identify mechanisms
of these disease progression and help us
develop therapeutic um
uh
a therapeutic intervention so no what I
was actually trying to say is the
chromosome 4 is what is associated with
the development of the Huntington
disease but when when they perform uh
these targeted sequencing effort in
these 100 1000 individuals with uh early
onset and late onset their differential
uh variant analysis resulted in
identifying specific regions of
chromosome 15 that had higher number of
copy number very or higher number of
copy number operation and for them right
those which which for those who contain
this higher number of copy number
operated chromosome 15 they are
associated with the slower development
of this Huntington disease and by
understanding this variant in particular
one can identify mechanisms of these
disease progression and relate that to
the therapeutic intervention
um by
naturally understanding the disease
regulation and Etc etcetera and that is
what this study actually helped us uh
understand in in specific so where uh
without any intervention and natural
variation that occurred for a specific
group of people
um acted as a potential regulatory
mechanism for a deadly disease we can
exploit to treat these specific early
onset of Huntington's diseases
so
proceeding further we can actually
turn our focus into pathogen genomics
data analysis in this case we already
know tuberculosis is so uh difficult to
to treat because they usually attack the
lungs and they can spread to other parts
of the body like brain spine Etc and
this is caused by microbacterium
tuberculosis why is this so important in
the 20th century alone tuberculosis was
the leading cause of death in the United
States and today most cases are usually
cured with very difficult to follow and
very complicated antibiotics regime
right but in the last three years or
four years
researchers have actually discovered
that this bacteria has become more and
more resistant to uh not one but several
different types of antibiotics so it
turns out that this resistance can be
associated with a specific set of
mutations in specific genes or their
promoters so understanding which Gene
and which antibiotic that that Gene uh
uh mutation I mean resistant to it which
antibiotic that that Gene is associated
to are very important in understanding
the development of resistance in general
so there are also large for example part
of developing new drugs to address this
surge of multi-drug resistant
tuberculosis infections themselves and
in addition to this multi drug resistant
tuberculosis there is an existence of
extensively drug resistant tuberculosis
which is resistant to all different
types of antibiotics or most of the
different types of antibiotics that is
it has been tested so there are multiple
studies that focuses on understanding uh
the population level or population
uh person
a distribution of this multiple drug
resistant and extensively drug resistant
tuberculosis from single infected uh
single infected isolated area and there
are also studies for example in uh as
you will know in in some of the example
projects that we have
um study 20 year 22 years old study
performed in single patient to
understand the development of drug
resistance to variety of different drugs
um that are that are used to treat that
specific patient so we have more
examples like examples in nebula virus
where we know that the viral protein VP
24 is is a nucleocapsin protein that is
associated with uh inhibiting interface
gene expression and interferon mediated
antiviral response so this actually
prevents the nuclear importer import of
the signal transducer and the activator
of the
Stat one and hence the interferon
mediated antiviral response is heavily
depleted in the Ebola virus affected
infected patients but several studies on
specific
strain of Ebola virus that that exist
with reduced transmissibility and
reduced
disease
pathogenicity or virulence actually
identifies specific mutations at
residues 142 146
um that are able to for example
reduce the
activity of the VP 24 by 90 percentage
right so this uh these mutations that
are naturally occurring where the result
or where the uh um were one of the
starting point that ended up uh helping
us develop vaccines for these Ebola
virus uh uh in this specific epidemic at
2014 2016. so there are other examples
as well for example
um this considers or this actually
discusses the use of
um
understanding the rhizophia rhizosphere
which is defined as the soil Zone around
the plant rooms right and this soil as
we know is is rich in nutrients and in
this region there is an intense
interaction that takes place between the
plant root tips and plant roots and the
microbes that are present in the soil
microbes that are represented the plant
floors right these microbes inhibiting
or inhabiting area are generally termed
as rhizobacteria and they can actually
regulate All the known biogeochemical
cycles of this specific space and they
can regret degradation of organic
chemicals and they can actually preserve
the
um components of the soil chemistry
and understanding the mutability or
mutation of uh of the for example
um
uh mutability uh of uh mutability in all
the positions uh of of this
rhizobacteria genome uh can actually
help us understand the
um variety and variation that is present
in uh several different rhizobacterial
genome in in specific there are
um there are a couple of Publications
that are involved in isolating specific
isobacteria genome and uh and in a and
in a genome-wide Association studies
gloss like studies in understanding the
heterozygosity of this specific Nitro
bacteria which we know are very
beneficial to ah
maintaining the healthy ingredients of
the soil
biosphere people actually characterized
mutations that are beneficial to
maintaining these
these interaction that are attending at
a at a healthy rate and some of the
mutations that are known to cause
depletion in the functionality of the
rhizobacterial rhizobacterium
genome in general so that is also
possible so this is not only limited to
for example uh
um understanding the bacterial genome
that that inhibits or that that are
inhibited of the Habit inhibited of the
soil rhizosphere one can also use
General genomics data analysis in in
promoting crop yield and in promoting
the genetics of Agriculture which
precedes the use of genomics in
agriculture by several decades so the
efforts in those areas are also heavily
uh are heavily advancing because
generally when you see the amount of
data that is available for us to compare
our samples with are focused more on
human genome and this is causing human
genes and less on uh General crop yields
and crop production and agriculture in
in in general so in those uh
um
in those aspects people focus on not
comparing the genome with the reference
genome if the reference genome is not
present then they
work out or then they
perform glass-like standardies in trying
to sample variety of different uh
genomes and understand the variation
that is present at different levels
inside the plant sequences Etc so this
is not limited to only plants this is uh
this can exist at different levels
um
also in in metagenomics levels also you
can
you will get
a deep and detailed understanding of of
these applications when you go through
some of the associated resources that
are listed in introduction to
bioinformatics and sometimes bison
molecules in the resources so we with
that I will conclude today's lecture and
in the next following
um
sessions we will focus more about uh
more about the important part of this
studies that are related to our ability
to compare the DNA code from given
individual to a reference right this
comparison is actually made possible
through the computational advances that
will take
millions of these short reads and align
themselves to the reference to extract
meaningful insights as we have been
discussing so far so the next session is
to understand the basic concepts of
sequence analysis through performing
these sequence analysis in in an
environment like R so you will start
with understanding what is the DNA
sequence string and why we need to
compare it with the reference sequence
and what do we gain by comparing it with
a reference sequence and what are the
what are the variants and we can
actually characterize you can perform
this alignment yourself and what are the
different types of alignment that one
can focus on and how to do a test
alignment in our case and how to do
similar analysis by uploading files in
in our Talbot bioinfo platform and
visualize the output
in J browser or igb Etc that will be our
discussion for the next session and if
you have any questions please let me
know in the chat box
and if there are no questions I will
pass on the session to Spurs
uh yes
so thank you doctor
for this wonderful session
so I will quickly navigate you all
through the program page once again for
those who have joined the first session
first free introductory session for the
very first time
so let me
share my screen
[Music]
a street body could you please confirm
if my my screen is possible
yes it is visible
so this is the program page and shivari
has already shared the link
[Music]
down you can see there is a program
overview which will give you a brief
about what like why this particular
program is designed why we are
conducting this particular program and
what all benefits one would gain or have
if they join this program
now on the right hand side you can see
the interactive sessions neighbors the
highlighted dates are the dates on which
we will be conducting our sessions for
genomic data analysis program
as you asked the second session is
that is Friday this week
and
uh today we covered these all topics so
it was an overview of genomic data
analysis program where we covered about
the overview of mutations variant
variations then molecular determinants
of phenotype or structure expectations
Etc
and the upcoming session is on 24 and
the title of the session is unreveling
genomics and working with DNA sequences
using R and here are the topics which
we'll cover understanding of DNA
variation DNA sequences and alignments
are NGS processing data formats and
Technical challenges mapping read
alignment and section of variance
[Music]
exploring pgb genomic variations working
with DNA sequences in rbsp logical block
and Google collab workbook and here are
the associated online resources
those who are like have enrolled for
this program for either 45 days 60 days
or 90 days 10 years you can also see the
session recording of the first session
that is of today's session by uh
tomorrow we upload the YouTube link here
on the program page itself those who
haven't enrolled for this particular
program I will quickly guide you through
how to enroll for this program and
control the tenure we have for which you
can uh enroll so as you can scroll down
you can also see the further curriculum
of this program on which particular date
uh I think the next sessions we will be
conducting their topics their online
Associated resources Etc
now talking about a for those particular
participants who have like not enrolled
for the programs but are interested to
do so so
this particular program like it is
divided into three tenures uh either 45
days or 60 days or 90 days now there are
some few common resources which one
would Avail if they enrolled for this
program that are online tutorials
project examples coding session session
recordings online meant to support via
Skype telegram or Whatsapp groups Online
technical support certificate after
completion of the program and example
Cloud pipelines on t-bio info server
which is used for the analysis part
now what's the difference between the
three in 45 days tenure you will have
the excess to an extensive training
related on genomic data analysis and
topics or the sessions and you will have
access to online mental support via
either Sky group or telegram group or
whenever there will be live Community
session or live session conducted
in 60 days you have an opportunity to
work you have an opportunity to uh work
or draft a research proposal and present
it to our Mentor for the evaluation and
then also you can conduct a one-on-one
Mentor sessions so that you can get your
queries clarified here one-on-one Zoom
meetings also and in 90 days you have an
opportunity to work on an independent
research project and further the outcome
is a research publication and also
one-on-one one-on-one mental sessions is
there
also you have an opportunity to get a
certificate of excellence after you
complete your research project via
research fellowship program and for us
in 90 days now talking about the pricing
for 45 days it's 7500 for 60 days it's
10 000 and for 90 days it's 15 000 and
right now we are providing with
scholarships and I
people on WhatsApp so whomsoever across
the globe is active on WhatsApp and they
need to directly or have one-on-one
conversation with me via WhatsApp call
also or a zoom meeting uh they can ping
me on the WhatsApp number or even they
can mail me and they can fix it's good
if you need to discuss further and what
would be the possible uh discounts on
the scholarship
so this was all about the uh
registration part and the scholarship
and yes we will be providing with the
insights of the session one for sure and
those who haven't enrolled for this
particular program please enroll
yourself up till the next session that
is on September 24th Friday
so please let me know if anyone is
having any query related to the
subscription part or registration part
or the fee or scholarship I'll be happy
to answer
thank you
all right with that I hope each of you
were able to learn something new from
today's session and like special if you
have any queries regarding the program
details or registration or free
structure please feel free to reach out
to her via the email or the contact
number that I've provided in the chat
box and with that thank you all for your
time and patience I hope to see you all
for session two of the program for that
thank you all once again and have a
great day thank you everyone
thank you SRI body and thank you